I have this incredible talent to fall
asleep anywhere I actually used to get
more sleep doing the Sleep stream could
you explain a sleep stream
the camera on while you're sleeping but
why do people tune into that for guys
they typically get more money doing it
because their chat's trying to mess with
them they're trying to wake the guy up
but girls chats environments are more
like
I don't know what the word is uh sexual
I guess so they'll be like like what if
she starts taking over top right now
forget she's streaming oh my God what I
would do to her right now like while
she's sleeping and others are like why
are you guys watching this y'all are
weird they're like criticizing each
other for watching it while they're
watching it how much would you make in a
sleep stream maybe like
10 to 15 000. that's wild we should
sleep stream tonight